[Musique]
on vous en a sûrement déjà parlé vous
les connaissez ces vidéos qui font le
buzz sur internet en passant du chat qui
joue du piano canular déjanté qui se
cache derrière ces sketches millions de
vues nous avons rendez vous avec thierry
père de famille de 45 ans qui vit en
banlieue avec sa femme et ses trois
enfants une famille ordinaire qui il y a
deux ans a subi un véritable coup dur
thierry a perdu son emploi pour des
raisons économiques clés ils ont fait
des millions de bénéfices
ils nous ont tous des règles aussi
multifils tong qui a vu que j'allais pas
bien et du coup pour me remonter le
moral il m'a montré une vidéo ou un
nullard sur youtube et r3 qui nous a
sauvé la vie quoi l'aumône amusé mais
surtout intrigué thierry fait quelques
recherches et apprend que les youtuber
vivent grâce à leur nombre de vues quand
j'ai su qu'un million de vues sur
youtube ça correspondait à 1000 balles
là j'ai tout de suite su que j'allais
faire du blé quoi vous montrer la
première vidéo
j'ai remplacé la pâte à tartiner pas la
confiture de figues fini c'est raté
lisa m la confiture de figues et a donc
mangé sa tartine normalement mais il ne
perd pas espoir au début j'ai fait
c'était pas dingue mais bon je suis pas
démotivé pour autant au début je voulais
faire je voulais faire du porno devant
son échec
thierry tente de passer au niveau
supérieur et dès 10h30 ma fille lisa
bank a relevé on va l'aider un peu il
faut se réveiller
lisa choqué et asphyxié par les gaz mais
plusieurs minutes à reprendre ses
esprits
faut se réveiller les jeunes à 150
milles 1 donc j'ai senti que j'étais sur
le bon filon bla eh ben je dois dire que
j'ai enchaîné qu'un petit bijou a changé
le boucher chez non mais c'est normal
c'est de la merde avec k pop
le résultat est immédiat malaises
vomissements
plein de bonnes choses qui garantissent
le buzz selon lui et ce n'est pas fini
après avoir vu la vidéo d'un cafard
envoyé dans l'espace
thierry décide d'envoyer sa fille zoé de
six mois saab ils y ont vu ça
aujourd'hui thierry compte bien filmé ce
qui sera son best-seller qu'ils comptent
appeler la maison hantée sa set démarre
à 38 tonnes ça ne sont pas si tu sens le
port
ça va ça ça c'est un serpent qui le
d'australie fais gaffe rigas à tes pieds
cléjà lupita a fait part à chaque fois
parmi ces un vrai psychopathe
travaillent tous à la pioche et ça s'est
rencontré sur doctissimo l'armateur lama
étant donné la violence des images de
cette vidéo nous ne pouvons que vous
montrez la façade extérieure de la
maison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon ben voilà avec cette dernière vidéo
bas on peut considérer qu'on a plus de
problème d'argent qu'on a qu'on a vu le
bout du tunnel et je peux vous dire que
c'est que le début voilà c'est que le
début ça je peux vous le dire
là on va envoyer du lourd je te quitte
et tu peux cliquer sur le macaron gold
and start abonnés ou sur l'assiette de
kaka afin de découvrir d'autres une idée
prend qu'à 67 5
et sinon par ici tu peux regarder notre
vidéo
[Musique]